so do you remember those two FBI agents
who had worked on the Muller
investigation and openly talked about an
insurance policy to undo the election in
case Trump won so it turns out the FBI
lost all of their text messages from
December 2016 all the way up until
precisely the day before the Muller
investigation began whoops
will analyze the seemingly endless
innocent little old coincidences and why
the government needs to find the texts
or fire Muller then conservative leaders
Steve lonegan and Vincent buta joined
the panel of deplorable to discuss
whether there's any hope for a daca deal
what the turpan house of horrors means
for home schooling and the new CNN poll
that shows Biden Bernie and Oprah all
leading Trump in 2020 I wonder if that
poll is like all the other CNN polls
that had Hillary crushing Trump in 2016
we'll find out I'm Michael Knowles's as
the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
before we get started today just a
shameless personal plug the Oscar
nominations are out I'm not going to
talk about them because no one has seen
any of the movies but we're nominated
I've missed about half of them and I
live in Hollywood and I'm in this
industry so I'm not gonna talk about
that what I will talk about though is
act like good culture actual culture not
these ridiculous movies that no one goes
and sees and then Hollywood gives each
other golden statues for it I mean
actual culture that Hollywood can't stop
and gatekeepers can't stop so andrew
Clavin and I have just completed another
Kingdom which is a narrative podcast
it's fairly innovative I don't think
anything like it has ever come out on
the right if at all if on either side of
the philosophical spectrum and it's a
great story about a 30 year old
Hollywood schlub who can't get a job in
Hollywood I'm not sure why he would ever
cast me I don't have no idea and he
walks through a portal into another
Kingdom and he's in another dimension
with damsels and ogres and a bloody
dagger and a dead woman at his feet and
we I know it sounds like Hollywood but
that's actually the other Kingdom so
this has been a 13-part series it's been
a lot of fun I'm performing all of the
roles and work live and wrote it
it's called another Kingdom please go
check it out right now you can binge the
whole thing so if you want to just set
it on your on a long car ride you just
can play them right in a row feel free
to do that we really appreciate it
leave us a five star review that helps
us out a lot of Hollywood production
houses and and Studios have called us
about it and then the night before the
meeting they Google Android clayvin and
then they the meeting goes terrible so
we want to force it down their throats
and put a stick in their eye so please
go to its another Kingdom Andrew Clavin
it's another Kingdom you can get it
anywhere fine narrative podcasts by
conservatives and bloody daggered
clothing anywhere you can download those
that's where you get it ok let's get
into some politics it sure looks like
the fix was in
in 2016 new documents show a lot of
collusion in the 2016 presidential
campaign not collusion with Trump and
Vladimir or Boris or Natasha
but between democrats and barack obama's
corrupt administrative agencies these
texts and documents and deleted texts
and classified documents are all
early confusing so let's go through it
carefully and get a broad view because
this is what they're counting on
Democrats are counting on this issue
being so confusing so opaque the
timeline is so unclear was so long ago
that Americans will just throw up their
hands and ignore what seems from every
indication to be rank corruption this
all begins with two FBI agents Peter
struck and that name by the way it's
spelled strug's ah gah gah course um
it's got like 15 sales and or 15
consonants in it rather Peter struts
oughta talk and Lisa Paige struck helped
lay the FBI's investigation into Hillary
Clinton's private email server and he
was involved in opening the
investigation into Russian meddling in
the 2016 presidential election he was
reassigned off of Muller's team to HR
duty when text messages turned up
demonstrating him clearly colluding with
other FBI officials to sabotage Trump's
campaign from within the government
struck was the number-two official in
counterintelligence and the leading
Russia expert he was sleeping with
another FBI agent Lisa page because it's
Washington DC so of course he was
sleeping with this other FBI agent his
girlfriend and co-conspirator Lisa Paige
was also on the mother team before
returning to the FBI but she had
finished her assignment already before
all of these texts came out so she
didn't have the opportunity to be fired
the day after President Trump was
elected president
struck in Paige texted about a secret
society within the Department of Justice
and the FBI working against Trump
working against the democratically
elected president was the exact word
secret society hears House Oversight
chairman trey Gowdy on the recent
findings we need to know a couple of
things number one we need to know how
the world's premiere law enforcement
agency managed to lose five months worth
of tax and what's also troubling is in
the text we do have they're discussing
how to avoid text being captured and
secured so what's missing is important
but but also what's there is important
it is manifest bias not just against
Trump but against his kids against this
business interest there's a text where
they hope the Trump Hotel fails that is
a level of bias that you rarely see and
you never see from law enforcement
officers what's also troubling to me
is this text that Johnny Radcliffe found
last night about this secret society now
I have no clue what that means because
that was not the phraseology I used but
it's the day after the election then
it's the same two people that were
discussing a little bit later in the
text the damage they had done with the
Clinton investigation and how they could
quote fix it and make it right that is a
level of bias that is stunning
among law enforcement has been right so
there may have been a secret society
within the DOJ and FBI working against
Trump including page and struck you'll
remember the first text exchange that
set off all of these questions about
whether the FBI and the DOJ were biased
against Trump from the beginning if this
entire investigation into Trump was just
a ruse to rout him out of office if it
was funded by Hillary Clinton and the
Democrat Party the first text which came
out in December was sent in August 2016
in the final months of the 2016
presidential election struck wrote
two-page quote I want to believe the
path you threw out for consideration
that there's no way he gets elected but
I'm afraid we can't take that risk
it's like an insurance policy in the
unlikely event you die before you're 40
it's like an insurance policy what is it
is it referring to the investigation
into Russian interference is it
referring to the Obama administration's
pretext for spying on the Trump campaign
which we know he did what is it what is
the insurance policy by the way Andy
here refers to Deputy FBI director Andy
McCain so it appears whatever political
dealings in government they're talking
about go all the way up to the upper
most Ashlyn's of the FBI Trump himself
called this exchange treason and he's
right this is an attempt of the
bureaucracy to subvert our democratic
republic I had the privilege of speaking
to Antonin Scalia about the federal
bureaucracy before he died I said what's
the greatest threat to freedom in
America to the Republic he said the
unaccountable executive agencies the
federal bureaucracies the greatest
threat to Liberty we might be seeing
that play out Struck's flax insist that
the insurance policy reference was meant
to convey
that the FBI needed to thoroughly and
lawfully investigate any improper
interference in the election you know
just do our job very well give me a
break
the implication then if that's the case
the implication is that the FBI
typically doesn't do its job is that
what struck is saying the FBI doesn't
normally do its job so to get the FBI to
do its job would be an insurance policy
in the unthinking event that the in the
unthinkable event rather that the
American people elect the president of
their choice so even if Struck's account
were credible and it's not the
implication would be that the FBI is so
hopelessly partisan and corrupt that the
FBI is following the law and doing its
job would be out of the ordinary but
then again Struck's account is not
credible struck a shot back through his
attorney who said quote it is beyond
reckless for the President of the United
States to accuse pete's truck a man who
has devoted his entire adult life to
defending this country of treason can we
get Benin to play the violin for this
absurd corrupt hack it should surprise
no one that the president has both the
facts and the law wrong is that right
mr. struck or rather it mr. struts a
lawyer because mr. struck won't say
anything on record because he was caught
red-handed conspiring with the Democrats
to overturn an American presidential
election struck by the way has retained
all-star lawyer David Boies
that's a Harvey Weinstein's lawyer it's
one of the most expensive lawyers in DC
interesting that he would be able to
retain someone so expensive on an FBI
salary because you know he gave his
whole life just to serve his country is
just a faithful public servant isn't he
but somehow you can afford the most
expensive lawyer in the country to
defend him against this these charges of
corruption gross corruption subverting a
democratic election so this guy the
lawyer is worth pointing it's worth
pointing on he is from the same firm as
Karen Dunn who was slated to become
Hillary's White House Counsel had she
defeated Donald Trump I just want to
point that out
I'm not making any any allegations just
just pointing out that strange
coincidence so that that's what's
reckless mm-hmm
now we have an investigation apparently
triggered by a senior FBI official who
is desperately opposed to Trump who
refers in a text to his colleague and
lover same say colleague / lover another
senior FBI official to an insurance
policy a fail-safe to take Trump out in
the event the American people actually
elect him an insurance policy that was
apparently cooked up in the office of
the deputy director of the FBI
those privately now uncovered text
exchanges also strongly imply that
former FBI director James Comey was
lying when he insisted that he had not
decided against charging Hillary Clinton
until after he interviewed her here's
Comey did you make the decision not to
recommend criminal charges relating to
classified information before or after
Hillary Clinton was interviewed by the
FBI on July the second after all I can
do is tell you again the decision was
made after that because I didn't know
what was gonna happen in that interview
was that right James that's right now
you know someone would lie this brazenly
you know while testifying be if he
thinks there's no way he's gonna get
caught there's no it's just a little of
course I made the decision afterward
that's just a thing that politicians
would say unfortunately here looks like
he got caught the text suggests
otherwise other than his testimony when
Obama's Attorney General Loretta Lynch
stated that she would accept whatever
recommendation the FBI made regarding a
prosecution of Hillary Clinton Paige
wrote quote this is a purposeful leak
following the airplane snafu purposeful
leak of course we all knew it was and
the airplane snafu was when Bill Clinton
met privately with Loretta Lynch on an
airplane presumably to pressure her to
let Hillary off the hook maybe he
threatened to suicide her if she didn't
know I'm kidding that's a joke am i I
don't know and now who knows what they
said I wasn't there but in any case
struck replied quote timing looks like
hell will appear to be choreographed uh
yeah yep it looks choreographed it's
true I wonder why it looks so
choreographed but then Paige replied
quote yeah it's a real Profile in
Courage since she knows no charges will
be brought since Loretta Lynch Obama's
Attorney General knows no charges will
be brought that exchanges from July 1st
hmm Hillary Clinton was interviewed by
the FBI on July 2nd July 1st July say
I'm no mathematician but I'm pretty sure
July 1st come
before July 2nd which means we have a
text from the day before her
interviewing her interview asserting
that everybody including Loretta Lynch
and James Comey knew at least the day
before Hillary's interview that they
would never charge her so it looks like
there was collusion after all not
between Trump and Khrushchev or whatever
nonsense they're alleging now but
between Barack Obama's corrupt
administration with its various
unaccountable bureaucratic agencies and
the Hillary Clinton campaign for
president in light of all of this and
calls from senior members of both
parties including Senate Majority
Leader's than a Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer to fire James Comey Trump fired
James Comey
James Comey with said let go for which
he is now being investigated for
obstruction of justice and now Trump
summed this up well to The Wall Street
Journal he said of course there was no
obstruction there was no crime they make
up a crime and the crime doesn't exist
and then they say obstruction everybody
wanted Comey fired I should be given
credit for having great insight
absolutely right also pretty funny but
also right Democrat Senator Dianne
Feinstein ranking member of the
Judiciary Committee has admitted they
have no evidence of collusion between
Trump and Putin or Stalin or Brezhnev or
whatever all-star Democrat flack Van
Jones admits what
that's right that's right the Russia
thing is just a big nothing burger even
one of the most prominent Democrat
messengers in the country admits it's a
big nothing burger but that's why
corrupt Democrats and their counterparts
in the US government bureaucrats so
convinced they can run our lives better
than we can run them ourselves that they
would subvert a free and fair election
that's why they needed an insurance
policy so now how about the cherry on
top
what's the cherry on top of the nothing
burger or of the nothing burger sundae
and mixing metaphors aren't whatever the
DOJ has just announced five months worth
of text exchanges between struck and
page upwards of fifty thousand text
messages between December 14th 2016 and
May 17th 2017 the day before Muller was
appointed special counsel one day before
Muller was appointed special counsel
those texts have just gone missing first
of all for before we get into the meat
of this what self-respecting man
exchanges 50,000 text messages with his
girlfriend i text sweet little elise of
once every 10 days at most and then it
is only to comment on how delicious
whatever lunch she made for me that day
is but then sweet little ELISA and I
aren't colluding to undo a presidential
election so I guess we have a lot less
to text about and now the texts are all
gone whoops whoops what are the odds
what a coincidence that the text
messages between two FBI agents who
openly boast about trying to sabotage
the democratically elected president and
overturn the election they all just went
missing from the transition period
through their appointment of the special
counsel whose investigation they both
worked on here is how the DOJ explained
it they said quote the Department wants
to bring to your attention that the
FBI's technical system for retaining
text messages sent and received on FBI
mobile devices failed to preserve text
messages for mr. struck and miss page
from December 14th to approximately May
17th oops well what can you do what can
you do sometimes look sometimes a
technical glitch erases five crucial
months of evidence central to the most
important issue being investigated by a
federal agency right isn't that just
what happens the devices just didn't
sync a new version of what
probably just updated it happens by the
way by the way none of that explains why
the texts aren't still on the devices
themselves so they're alleging the
messages didn't backup to the cloud or
the federal cloud or whatever okay why
aren't the message is still on the
devices did the FBI sell the phones on
Fiverr for 50 bucks a pop or something
like that the department wants to bring
to your attention that the FBI system of
selling old Bureau devices on Craigslist
to help pay for the pixel to failed to
preserve text messages from mr. struck
and miss page got it by the way by the
way during the time of the supposed
glitch a few important things happened
there's just the glitch when all the
texts went away just a few things
happened in that period
Milind mister struck it might have been
texting each other about these things
the publication of the totally unproven
anti-trump fusion gps dossier funded by
hillary clinton and the DNC that may
have been used as pretext to kick off
the whole investigation of Trump and
Russia that happened you know Democrats
possibly bankrolling a government witch
hunt of their political opponents On
January 20th also in that time frame
Trump was sworn into office on January
24th struck interviewed former trunk
advisor Michael Flynn on March 2nd Jeff
Sessions recused himself from any
investigations involving the campaign in
Russia
on March 4th Trump predicted correctly
it turns out that Barack Obama used the
government to spy on his campaign on May
9th Trump fired James Comey at the
encouragement of virtually every
politician in the US on both sides of
the aisle and on May 17th
Deputy Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
appointed Robert Muller special counsel
to investigate Trump the FBI only lost
text messages from those months Fox News
asked the FBI on Monday whether they had
failed to preserve text message records
on similar devices belonging to other
officials during that time period
because the FBI had blamed the Samsung
Galaxy 5 for failing to sync and I will
tell you something as the former owner
of a Samsung Galaxy 5 phone that is the
only credible claim that the FBI has
made during this entire ordeal that
phone is just a piece of trash half the
time it doesn't make phone calls if the
GPS feature when you're driving it'll
just tell you what you should have done
so you're like two blocks after you
missed the turn it's a
should have turned anyway Fox News asked
if the FBI had lost text messages from
similar devices belonging to other
agents at that time and wouldn't you
know the FBI had no comment on the
matter so there goes that excuse one has
to assume that if the FBI had lost other
text messages from similar devices
during that time they would have taken
out a front page ad in the New York
Times to try to slow down the avalanche
of corruption allegations but nope no
comment so here's the deal I haven't
been one of the Republicans or
conservatives calling on Trump to fire
Muller
even though Muller is friends with call
me even though Muller appears to have
staffed his investigation with anti
Trump operatives even though the
original rush investigation itself may
have been triggered by Democrat money I
still urged caution let it play out
don't interfere this is a bridge too far
the missing text messages is a bridge
too far I'm not even impugning Mulder's
personal reputation here is personal
integrity I don't know if he's a hack or
if he's some stand-up guy I don't care
this is a bridge too far the FBI the DOJ
Bob Muller they don't need to find these
text messages I don't even care in the
spirit of reconciliation they can just
call off the investigation which has
been a partisan witch hunt from the
beginning and which we're seeing more
clearly every day but that's the choice
find the text or fire Muller as Hillary
Clinton ironically pointed out refusing
to accept the results of a presidential
election is a direct threat to our
democracy we can't tolerate this
flagrant threat any longer okay let's
get into our panel we have got a good
panel today we've got former mayor of
Bogota New Jersey and all-around
conservative leader Steve lonegan
and Vincent beautiful live from Studio
6b but before we talk to them I have to
talk about something much more important
than any of that our government or our
great panel today or another Kingdom
I've got to talk about DaVinci DaVinci
another sponsor that helps us keep the
lights on in Co FFA and our cup we
appreciate them very much and DaVinci is
a really great service so da Vinci
offers incredibly affordable meeting
rooms in well-known office locations in
every city if you're like me and you're
traveling and you've got to get some
business done usually you'll just duck
into some coffee shop where the internet
isn't that great and there are people
yelling bizarre things all around you
and you'll try to take a conference call
in there and it'll just sound very
unprofessional and then the thing will
cut it out and then you have to sign up
for internet blah blah blah it's no it's
no fun right now
da Vinci has a solution to this it's you
can find the perfect meeting room for
face-to-face business meetings it's as
easy as search book meet search book
meet there's nothing else you don't need
to you know give up hours and hours of
your life to make this happen it's
search book meet so whether you need a
day office or a conference room a
boardroom or a training space you just
need a room to Vinci has the right room
for you when you need it like for me
obviously we broadcast from the broom
closet of the ben shapiro show and
sometimes you need a little bit more
space so you can use da Vinci to have a
little more breathing room and you're
not just sitting you know nose to nose
with somebody else so let's say you're
based in Phoenix but you need to meet
customers face to face in New York or LA
or Omaha skip the coffee shop go to a
DaVinci meeting room instead search book
meet it's super easy from day offices to
conference rooms da Vinci gives you
instant access to over 5,000 affordable
meeting rooms in well-known office
locations in every city you might think
well they'll have this in New York and
LA or something this thing is everywhere
so search book and meet your DaVinci
meeting room comes with high-speed
internet and all the presentation tools
to make your next meeting a success now
how much would you pay for this a
gazillion dollars I pay I would pay
marshals annual salary if I could which
isn't saying a ton necessarily obviously
he makes about the same as I do here
which is scraps but what would you give
to have this opportunity it's just ten
bucks ten bucks an hour that is nothing
if I go to a coffee shop and get a latte
probably more than that to have a
meeting space which isn't nearly as
useful remember these three words three
words I'm gonna tell you search book
meet so if you go to da Vinci com I'm
sorry da Vinci meet dot-com da Vinci
Davi MC I meet M eet com slash coffe FA
Co V Fe Fe for a limited time you will
get 50% off your first purchase that's
da Vinci meet comm / cough FA terms and
conditions apply don't they always don't
they to everything in life go to
Vinci meet dot-com / coffe FAC of EF EF
e you will not regret it it is a great
solution Marshall what's that address /
cup FA do it do it now gentlemen Oh God
oh my gosh I've got Steve lonegan and
Vincent beauty here all I want that we'd
at least get through one topic first but
Marshall that tyrant that sadist is
telling me that if you are not on daily
wery calm you can't see it sorry folks
so you got to go to daily wire.com right
now why is that well if you sign up it's
just ten bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you'll get me you'll
get the interplay van sure you get the
Ben Shapiro show you get no ads on the
website you get the conversation you can
ask me anything you want that's gonna be
coming up soon blah blah blah who cares
you get this look folks when the rank
corruption of the Obama administration
the the infection of all these federal
agencies all of the texts all of the
insurance policies come out you are
going to be drowning and left as tears
and you need an insurance policy you
need an insurance policy don't let it
happen to you don't protect your family
and yourself and your home get the
leftist here's tumblr you can have them
all a salty and delicious all the time
either hot or cold go to daily wire calm
we'll be right back
gentlemen thank you for being here
Vincent you've been here before Steve
lonegan your first time here Steve for
those of you who don't know you Steve is
this great figure in the conservative
movement and the Republican Party former
mayor in New Jersey I think did you
climb a mountain or something did I read
that somewhere yeah I did kill him and
you're also a client of DaVinci I use
their office space many times your
sponsor have you yeah all right we've
got a we've got a panel and all over the
place yep
wonderful yeah that I I think it's a
great opportunity I got a broadcast from
New York later in the spring and we're
certainly gonna be using those guys so
okay so we've got a former mayor
all-around great conservative activist
climbed Kilimanjaro you know just a
little thing so you've got a little
that's right you know you've got this
broad array of experiences from your
meanderings around politics and the
conservative movement does Trump need to
fire Muller is the Russian investigation
too tainted with partisan machinations
at this point I think the first thing
that happens it has to happen is Jeff
Sessions Unruh cues himself and the DOJ
should take a much more hands-on
approach to this investigation because
you know these missing eat these missing
text message are equivalent to the
Watergate tapes in my opinion I think
they're gonna be very unveiling the
reason there were so many taxes goes
obviously they were planning something
planning something big you know I have
long been loath to criticize the Trump
administration I think everything that
people freaked out about is nothing it's
a nothing burger to quote Van Jones the
tweets and the this and that I think
that's all fine the one mistake was Jeff
Sessions recusing himself I felt that
was such a misstep so unnecessary
it gave Democrats such unnecessary
leverage Vincent what is going to be the
outcome of this investigation you're in
New York you know that you can indict a
ham sandwich is anything going to come
from this if it were you or I if it were
any individual we'd be in jail by now
number one and number two
I agree with Steve Jeff Sessions needs
to wake up here you know you have
Rosenstein who's now you know the
second-in-command and handling.this
whose hands are all over this
you've got mccabe you've got struck you
have all these guys KO me and this by
the way one of the things that I've been
thinking about about this entire
controversy is visceral connected the
Hillary email campaign and this whole
Trump you know Barry Trump thing that
we're talking about here with the
missing fifty thousand text and all of
this stuff they're connected it's a lot
of the same people they couldn't they
saved Hillary but they couldn't get her
elector elected and when they did they
tried to bury Trump you know we need
Dianne Feinstein now to step in and get
a cold to find those 50,000 text
messages maybe that's the right thing to
do that's absolutely right you know Mike
this whole issue that took place between
struck and his girlfriend and
potentially other FBI agents and
substantial people in the FBI which
would be unveiled by this text message
very well could raise the level of
treason if people in the FBI were
working actively to undermine the
election of the president United States
that could very well qualify as the
president said as treason so they need
to dig in really deep on this this is
way bigger than any phony Russian
collusion which I think we all know now
never took place and and it is crazy
there was a formerly very important
leader of the conservative movement I
like him personally so it won't be too
mean to him but he said when President
rump was elected he said between the
deep state and the Trump State I choose
the deep state and that is the worst
possible take I can imagine we're
talking about the foundations of our
Republic we're talking about the right
to self-government itself and saying
that we can run our own lives in our own
country better than some little band of
self-appointed elites and bureaucrats in
a far distant Capitol and if we see them
flexing their muscles and trying to
undercut a democratic election
presidential election that is a high
high crime and you and I don't think
you've overstated it and I don't think
Trump overstated okay we gotta get to
the news shoe
is under fire for losing the government
shutdown to trump he lost Schumer
sellout was trending on Twitter Politico
admitted Democrats lost moveon.org
called it a bad outrageous deal Pro
amnesty activists called it political
malpractice des cave heard round the
world
now Schumer is insisting that funding
for the border wall is off the table
Steve this is only a stopgap measure
that reopened the government the
government is funded through February
8th what happens then it comes roaring
back on February 8th and the whole issue
of amnesty is gonna be on the table but
we're gonna see where people stand
because what what Schumer has succeeded
in doing is forcing apparently if I'm
reading this correctly a simple up or
down vote on daca and that's gonna make
people take a stand it could be quite a
debate and actually I kind of prefer it
that way cuz let's get it over with look
the people the American people want the
wall they want an end to chain migration
they want merit-based immigration they
want they want to put an end to the visa
or lottery system whatever you want to
call it this is what the American people
want and this is what Donald Trump is
pushing for and this is what the
Republican Congress and Senate need to
deliver if I was in Congress right now
I'd be fighting every day to implement
just those policies but we're gonna see
what happens by February 8 absolutely
the vast majority of Americans the vast
majority oppose amnesty even for daca
even for these people who were brought
here at a relatively young age even for
the most sympathetic group of illegal
aliens they oppose amnesty only 44
percent of Democrats support amnesty for
the daca people for that's of Democrats
those are the Pitt is a clear issue it's
clear to the American people it's just
apparently not clear to squishes and
radical Democrats in Congress that's
right to limit Lindsey Graham misty as
even he admitted he's often called
Vincent if Republicans do nothing by
February 8th then we don't give amnesty
to scores of New Democrat voters and
non-essential government services remain
closed is that supposed to be a threat
is that is that that sounds okay to me
what is the incentive to negotiate
anything here yeah I mean I hear what
you're saying but this is
almost a no-win situation because the
American people and Trump's entire you
know presidency they need immigration
reform he needs to get immigration
reform Obama couldn't do it with 60
seats and everything that Steve noted
those are all the things that the
American people want the Redeemer kratts
however have no incentive to do anything
other than obstruct a trump demagogue
make him look bad this entire process
that is the agenda that's why the
government shutdown that's why they're
going back on February 8th and it's
gonna be a circus again and I think at
the end of the day we elected Trump to
hold the line and be tough ear and not
cave and and I think it's going to be a
bit of an impasse and they're nuts and
they think that their own base is
further left than even that is I'm sorry
Steve go ahead there's gonna be a whole
lot of swing state Democrats on the
ballot and then you'll be looking at
what the constituents want and looking
at these numbers I think we can get to
60 votes in the Senate to end chain
migration to build that wall to end the
visa system and to adopt merit-based
immigration because of that simple thing
called the American election system so
those Democrats are gonna have their
careers on the line and they know it
they know it if I were a Democrat of
running it either in Congress running
for Congress in a swing state this year
I would be terrified of this because the
leaders of the Democrat Party they think
that their base is left of Lenin they
think that their base wants to give
amnesty to everybody they don't it isn't
true
among any demographic of the American
people including among Democrats but
that's fine let him do it we're gonna
run up a bunch of good Republican
candidates now we have to move on
calculation Michael that's their big
miscalculation they are believing in the
very very small fringe of their party
and I think I think they're gonna get
burned mm-hmm speaking of bizarre small
fringes we've all heard about the Turpin
case that insane couple who starved and
tortured their 13 children and shackled
them to furniture I think they're out
here in my state of California of course
glorious little Oh California now the
media are focusing on one aspect in
particular that the terpenes here were
homeschooling their children of course
they weren't actually
schooling them or schooling them in any
way at all but according to the
government they were homeschooling them
so left-wing outlets like the week have
written about the sickening danger of
homeschooling Steve is this bizarre case
evidence that we need more government
regulation of homeschooling it's more
evidence that the press should be
covering the sickening cases of these
abortion clinic houses of horrors that
have spread of court all across the
country that they seem to forget to talk
about you know it homeschooling is just
a fantastic aspect of our American
society I'm a major supporter of
homeschooling it's actually sick to
tarnish the emission of whole school is
because of sick people like this because
our society our system police the
community whatever failed to know that
this was going on under their very noses
it is a deeply disturbing thing that
took place with this family something
that should never happen again
but it's certainly not affordable not
that the fault of home schoolers and
homeschooling should never be blamed for
to please of course you know you bring
up on that house of horrors a place like
Kermit Gosnell the worst mass murderer
in American history ran a bloody awful
abortion clinic limbs and carcasses and
things left all over the place that's
right we don't see that practice but the
press wouldn't cover it they blacked out
the whole thing they wouldn't cover it
and then this one bizarre savage
torturous couple now they say we need to
end homeschooling Vincent at public
schools 17,000 cases of student on
student sexual assault have been
reported in a four year time frame
according to a 2004 Department of
Education study sex abuse of students in
schools across the country is 100 times
worse than the widely reported on
priests sex abuse scandal of the early
2000s 27 percent of public school kids
in the u.s. attend schools that are gang
and drug infected according to a 2010
national survey why are the media so
quick to gang up on homeschooling
because of one depraved couple but
they're silent on the sorry state of
government schools yeah well that's
because the media is clearly just always
been in collusion with the left and
their government programs but what they
seem to jump on
and try to claim that government can
solve the problems when there's one
isolated incident like this terrible
story in the turbine house they jump on
that and try to make that a national
issue like it looked like they need to
jump in and do this whole homeschooling
government interjection it's ridiculous
the this is what's happened with so many
issues in this country even daca you can
point to on this when they just embrace
this and turned it into the whole
immigration issue the stuff going on in
the schools and government schools and
all that type of stuff I have to say if
the media will more open-minded to
actual journalism and I I I'm I'm I try
every day to try and find someone who's
because a real journalists out there are
these days to report fairly on anything
and I'm not saying it and here's this
these are just examples of that they're
not looking at the real issues that they
should be investigating and talking
about these stories they're bringing
things out that get kind of partisan ish
or ideology ish you know and that that
that drives me crazy and that can hit
drives everybody crazy I'm sure that
inflation is so insane I'm sorry go
ahead Steve do we have you yes sorry go
ahead would you say well they're pushing
a left-wing agenda I mean this is a
socialist movement it's been percolating
under the surface of this country going
back for decades and is still out there
they've infiltrated the media they've
infiltrated Hollywood they've
infiltrated our bureaucracy and they
continue to push Bush and Bush a
left-wing agenda and part of that agenda
is to undermine the very core principles
of Western civilization and a lot of
what you see going here on here is just
that to immediately jump on home
schooling where parents take charge of
their children's line which is a
fundamental human right a fundamental
responsibility just shows you where they
want to go with this country that's
right and their kidney always conflate
to all of these bizarre things so
there's one little crazy family in
California is now to be conflated with
all of homeschooling just as Vincent
pointed out they take the daca people a
25% of whom are illiterate 50% of who
don't have a really working Inglot
amande of the English language and they
say that if you don't support giving
immediate amnesty to these illegal
aliens then your anti-immigrant or use
I don't want immigrants in the country
it's ridiculous slights of hand with the
language and yeah we should we should
hold them to account for that last topic
a new CNN poll shows Biden Bernie and
Oprah leading Trump in 2020 57 to 40 55
to 42 and fifty one to forty two
respectively Steve are these numbers
legit do we need to fear President Oprah
Winfrey and I I just remember election
night and watching all the CNN guys big
smiles on their faces go to the end of
Donald Trump I remember their faces
later that night they were all just it
was absolutely hilarious these polls
mean absolutely nothing this economy is
booming the American people are thrilled
with the direction this country is going
in you're gonna see Republicans keep the
House of Representatives come November
and the Senate and maybe even pick up
seats and I think that very well could
happen if things continue to go the way
they're going and you're gonna see a
second term for President Donald Trump
you also I will predict in the next two
years whether what second two years of
the first Trump term you need to see
another tax cut bill coming into place
more cuts and regulations and more
economic growth so CNN can continue
their pipe dream I believe Michael that
they use these polls to try to influence
public opinion ahead of time just not
going to work absolutely right these
polls are just a communication strategy
they're just a regular old Democrat
tactic no reason to believe them Vincent
the combined age of Joe Biden and Bernie
Sanders is 487 do Democrats have any
valuable young talent for 2020 it's it's
fairly pathetic right today we're
talking about a CNN poll and I agree
with everything that Steve said but if
the Democrats were smart and I don't
want to give them a tip here but if they
were smart they'd find a centrist a
candidate in the middle that was younger
and stronger and pushed them forward
because the direction they're going
and then the media's ideology you know
riding with them shotgun it's not the
right direction for the country number
one and I think it's the wrong direction
for them as a party if they were smart
they'd get out of the weeds with with
these these retreads here Joe Biden and
Bernie I mean seriously Oh
I mean I can't even take that seriously
I think it's a better chance of finding
the 50,000 lost text messages then than
believing that survey by the way that
entire party needs an overhaul and they
need to get to the middle if they want
any chance and I don't want to give them
that advice maybe we need to edit
welcome we'll edit that Adam post
alright thank you
alright gentlemen that's our whole show
we're out of time I'm sorry I could keep
you here all day Steve lonegan Vincent
buta thank you both for being here
that's our show today
come back tomorrow get your mailbag
questions and we'll be doing the mailbag
on Thursday I am Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Knowles show come back
tomorrow we'll do it all again
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy bore senior producer Jonathan hey
supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex Zangaro
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina herons
makeup is by Joshua Avera the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for word
publishing 2018